l'année du bac c'est l'année la plus
ferme ta gueule c'est la dernière fois
que tu m'interrompes tu as compris sinon
je viens chez toi je séduis ta mère et
je t'ai fais des petits
frères ça fait 60 ans que le lycée
s'affronre dans une olympiade nous
sommes la risée de tout le monde mais
pourquoi on naappelle pas les secp mais
ça c'est une excellente mauvaise idée on
est des tueurs en sport mais bon c'est
dommage qu's sont enfermés à Marseille
c'est les sec pas si il s'agissait de
des
glaces si c'était du free fight des
neiges oh il fa quoi vous tout à
relè-toi je dirais mais mais allons-y
mais là c'est du sport
d'hiver m faites en sorte qu'il soit là
dès demain tu là cherché dans une
bergerie tu as tenue ou quoi c'est ta
grand-mère la foule de neige qui me l'a
[Musique]
prêté